Today we'll learn how to
build a great Android TV app.
Android TV is just Android
on a new form factor.
So, if you're all ready proficient
with Android development,
your existing skills will still apply.
First, we'll work through
a starter project and
explain how the key pieces work,
step by step.
Next, we'll apply these concepts
that we've learned by enhancing
the mobile version of
the universal media player to
also run on the TV form
factor in the very same APK.
Here's how the universal media
player looks when we start and
here's how it looks when we're done.
How cool is this?
It's complete with high
quality animations and
a responsive cinematic UI.
[MUSIC]
To build our app, we're going to
leverage the Leanback Support Library.
The Leanback Library is so
easy to use and so
versatile that it's becoming synonymous
with writing Android TV apps.
In fact,
this entire UI was built using Leanback,
with very little coding on our part.
That said though,
Leanback is just a library.
You don't have to use it at all.
And you have complete freedom over
how your app looks and feels.
Now, if you have an existing app you'd
like to run on the big screen, it's
important not to reuse the same activity
layout that you already have for
phones and tablet's.
Although, technically this will
work on Android TV, it'll make for
a poor user experience.
And if you do that,
Timothy Jordan will get angry and
you don't want to see him angry.
In reality, Timothy's a super
nice guy but just to be sure,
your UI should be simple,
cinematic, and fun.
For this lesson,
all you'll need is Android studio.
We'll use a TV emulator to run our
code so everyone can participate.
If you happen to have a real TV device
though, you can use that as well.
In fact, I'd strongly recommend using
a real device instead of an emulator for
developing production apps.
Sound good?
Let's get our app running
on the big screen.